hello it's so good to see you
congratulations on the movie
thank you perry good to see you you too
to start here i wanted to know what it
was like
for you working with thea who has a very
extensive theater background especially
as an actor with a lot of experience in
theater yourself
well it sure did there's a she has a
real collaborative process
a theatrical background um
loves to rehearse as do i uh loves to
talk about it
and and has an open door policy so
open to any whim or suggestion that may
come up on the set or otherwise
and that's the most you can hope for
in in a director is that not only do
they have a clear vision like she had
but also to be able to accept um
spontaneous
uh ideas that come up and try things not
not to be too rigid in how you approach
it and thea
is a wonderfully collaborative and
artistic uh partner
and can you tell me a little bit about
working with ben bishop it actually
wasn't until i read the press notes that
i realized how heavy
motion capture was involved here all the
animals were cgi
um and green men in green masks
wheeling around you know big metal
structures on wheels with
a a shape of an elephant that would
become the big elephant or
a puppeteer with the dog or all
different kinds of things
but ivan was ben bishop who was a
terrific actor and an improvisation
artist
and and he brought so much to it that
helped me tremendously
acting off of him even though he had no
lines
um that that but his character was very
real
and he was wearing a motion captain's
capture suit
that they replaced him completely with
ivan
and so you know we will see um
behind the scenes where ben leans
forward as i lean forward and our
our foreheads touch and and
then they replace him with someone it's
really a remarkable experience and
the technology has advanced so much
these animals look absolutely real
and it also they have a a sense of
anthropomorphism with it to where we
feel that they're
somewhat human or they convey human
thoughts and feelings
and now before i let you go i do have to
ask about better call saul i know it's
an ongoing conversation here
but one is there any chance we could see
you pop up on the series
as walt before it comes to a close and
is there any chance you're finally going
to direct an episode
i'll answer the second one first i have
been asked to direct
an episode uh every single season
and it just didn't work out or
because of a commitment to doing a play
or doing a movie or something and
so i wasn't able to section out the
times
available um but i do love the show
i think it's a fantastic show i
would be in it if if vince gilligan and
peter gould who
are co-executive producers on it uh
wanted me to be in it i would do it in a
second
um but it hasn't happened
yet i can tell you and we'll see i don't
know i mean there's one more season to
go and
we'll see what happens if the emmys keep
on coming in the brand is going to keep
growing so it gives you a lot of room to
jump back in
who knows we'll we'll see what happens
it's it's an exciting time for them
thank you so much for chatting with me
and again congrats on the movie very
much good to see you